It was a wet, cold, wind overcast day on March
4, 1841.
This didn’t matter to the thousands that
had come out to the nation’s capital to
see the president-elect William Henry Harrison
be sworn into office as the 9th President
of the United States.
With people lining the streets all the way
to the Capitol, it was described by John Quincy
Adams as the largest crowd the city had ever
seen and, by a historian later, as the most
raucous celebration since George Washington’s
1789 inauguration.
Despite his boring style and advanced age,
Harrison’s military acumen while battling
Indians in order to open western settlements
earlier in the century had made “Old Tippecanoe”
a populist candidate very much in line with
the Andrew Jackson.
With temperatures in the mid-40s, Harrison
rode through the streets not in a magnificent
carriage that was built specifically for him,
but – at his insistence – on a white horse.
He wore no overcoat, gloves or hat because
he felt it made him look undignified.
After being sworn in, he stepped to the podium
and began his inauguration speech as such:
Called from a retirement which I had supposed
was to continue for the residue of my life
to fill the chief executive office of this
great and free nation, I appear before you,
fellow-citizens, to take the oaths which the
Constitution prescribes as a necessary qualification
for the performance of its duties; and in
obedience to a custom coeval with our Government
and what I believe to be your expectations
I proceed to present to you a summary of the
principles which will govern me in the discharge
of the duties which I shall be called upon
to perform.
Yes, that’s one very long sentence.
His speech would go on to tally 8,445 words
and take nearly two hours.
To this day, it’s the longest inauguration
speech in American history.
Exactly one month later, William Henry Harrison
died – making him the first President to
die in office and the shortest tenured president
ever.
While it’s often implied (and sometimes
explicitly stated) that he died as a result
of that lengthy speech in the cold, this doesn’t
appear to be the case.
He did not get sick until three weeks after
his speech and it appears not from anything
temperature related.
(And if you’re curious, see Why Do People
Seem to Get More Colds in the Winter?)
His doctors didn’t help, regularly bleeding
him with leeches, among other “treatments,”
which we’ll get into shortly.
While Old Tippecanoe’s presidency was – unlike
his inaugural address – very, very short,
his life’s story was far from it.
At times during the campaign, Harrison would
refer to himself as a child of the American
Revolution.
This wasn’t simply a boast, but also true.
William was born as the youngest child to
the wealthy and influential Harrison family
of Virginia on February 9, 1773.
Counted among family friends were famed names
like Jefferson, Madison and Washington.
Even more impressively, Benjamin Harrison
(William’s father) was named a delegate
to the Continental Congress and was an original
signer of the Declaration of Independence
(which note was not signed until August of
1776, not July 4th as is so often stated).
Because of his family’s connections, there’s
little doubt that young William met some of
his Revolutionary heroes.
In fact, with his father convinced that he
was destined for a career in medicine, he
was sent to Philadelphia to study under Benjamin
Rush – another signer of the Declaration
of Independence.
However, being a doctor was never the youngest
Harrison’s destiny.
When his father died in 1791, he joined the
military and used his family name to secure
an officer’s rank.
He made his way to the Northwest Territory
and worked under General “Mad Anthony”
Wayne (named as such for his daring attack
on the British during the Revolutionary War)
at Fort Washington – near present-day Cincinnati.
Harrison’s job there was to help Wayne open
land for settlement, which meant fighting
natives and forcing them from land that was
deemed under American control.
This is how Harrison began to make a name
for himself – battling Native Americans.
When Wayne died, Captain Harrison took over
military control of the Northwest Territory.
In 1798, after resigning from the Army, he
was named Secretary of the Northwest Territory
by President Adams and its first delegate
to Congress.
In 1800, the territory split into two – the
Ohio and Indiana Territory – and Harrison
was named governor of the latter.
As governor, he was able to make himself a
good deal of money through land speculation.
But perhaps his worst offense was his exploitation
of the Native population with a land grab
that was driven by trickery and force.
According to the Miller Center at the University
of Virginia for the American Presidency, Harrison
took advantage of the Native Americans inability
to grasp the European idea of land ownership.
He pushed for the signing of treaties that
were written to intentionally confuse them.
In addition, he exploited their inexperience
with European alcohol (contrary to popular
believe, Native Americans had various forms
of alcohol before the Europeans arrived),
using it to lower their inhibitions and having
them accept deals that were pennies on the
dollar.
This eventually led to war with the Native
American leader Tecumseh.
On the banks of a small river in today’s
Indiana called Tippecanoe, Harrison was able
to fight off Tecumseh and his warriors mostly
to due to overwhelming numbers and superior
arms.
Nonetheless, Harrison became the talk of the
young nation for fighting off the “Indian
insurrection.”
As the Miller Center puts it, “The Battle
of Tippecanoe was good for William Henry Harrison
and no one else.”
In 1813, Tecumseh and Britain joined forces
in attempts to embarrass Harrison and the
United States during the western portion of
the War of 1812.
Again, Harrison’s outfit triumphed thanks
in large part to simply having more men.
His military reputation followed him over
the next two and half decades which allowed
him to run and be nominated for various offices,
including Congressmen, Senator and ambassador
to Columbia.
To many, it seemed Harrison’s ultimate goal
was not public service, but to supplement
a grandiose lifestyle.
He moved in and out of debt numerous times
in his career, often coming into money only
to spend it right away.
John Quincy Adams once said that he believed
Harrison had a “rabid thirst for lucrative
office.”
Nonetheless, in 1836 he was nominated by the
newly formed Whig party to run for President
(along with two other Whig candidates all
with the intent to stop Martin Van Buren from
becoming President).
In 1840, he was nominated again with the express
purpose of running against Jackson principles
(which Van Buren represented).
Despite Harrison’s own love for the finer
things in life, he was presented as a direct
contrast to the previous administration – a
western man who was dull, lived in a log cabin
and a military hero rather than a bureaucrat.
This worked, despite it being ultimately false,
and Harrison throttled Van Buren in the election,
amassing nearly 80% of the electoral vote.
During the campaign, there were already hints
that Harrison would not make it his full-term.
He had been sick throughout the campaign,
while also enduring the recent loss of a child.
At the time, he was also the oldest person
to be ever elected president.
150 years later, he would be eclipsed by Reagan
(who was just out-olded by the recent election
of Donald Trump).
On inauguration day, his very long speech
detailed several things that are essentially
his only Presidential record.
He criticized the shift of centralizing power
under the executive branch that had happened
under Jackson and Van Buren, while claiming
he would not run for a second term.
Harrison said he would not interfere in the
financial policies of the states, nor in their
right to determine their own slaveholding
laws.
(Harrison was slaveholder himself.)
He also pledged to pull the country out of
the economic depression it was in.
It was three weeks after the inauguration
that Harrison first told a doctor that he
felt ill.
Complaining of fatigue and anxiety, he was
prescribed rest and various “medicines”
that we would never ingest today (like acetate
of ammonia and mercury-tinged liquids).
Over a course of a week, Harrison gradually
fell iller.
His doctor was convinced that it was pneumonia,
but his notes showed otherwise – with constant
recordings of bowel movements and intestinal
pain.
On April 3, 1841, President Harrison uttered
these (apparently) last words: “Sir, I wish
you to understand the true principles of government;
I wish them carried out, I ask nothing more.”
The legend has always been that Harrison had
died from pneumonia contracted from refusing
to wear a coat while spending hours in the
cold and rain during his inauguration.
However, in 2014, two doctors from the University
of Maryland School of Medicine concluded that
he likely died from enteric fever – or typhoid
fever – as a result of drinking contaminated
drinking water.
During the mid-19th century, DC sewage was
often dumped in a marsh that was located upstream
of the White House’s water supply.
It’s very possible that the bacteria-infused
water seeped into the drinking water of the
President, giving him the much-dreaded typhoid
fever.
As noted by the doctors, this poorly-designed
White House architectural feature also may
have been the cause of death President Taylor
in 1850 and Lincoln’s son William in 1862.
Harrison’s quick death inspired a Constitutional
crisis, as never before had a sitting President
died while in office.
The Constitution did not state with clarity
what happens.
It does say that the presidency “shall devolve
on the Vice President” (which in this case
was John Tyler), but it did not say if they
would be simply the “acting” president
until another was elected in a special election
or they would become President until the next
scheduled election.
Tyler took the job and proposed these questions
to the Supreme Court, Harrison’s cabinet
and Congress.
But no one would come to a clear, decisive,
consensus-driven decision.
So, Tyler decided that he would be President
until the next election – which was four
years later in 1844.
He took a public oath of office on April 6th
(three days after Harrison’s death).
Detractors gave him the nickname “His Accidency.”
It wouldn’t be until 1967 with the 25th
Amendment that clear succession rules were
put into law.